[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui arrivé à l'âge adulte
avec le recul que j'ai ayant moi même
des enfants je réalise que j'ai eu une
enfance très heureuse et ça je le dois à
deux personnes ces deux personnes c'est
mon père et ma mère et j'aimerais
profiter de cette scène aujourd'hui pour
faire quelque chose que j'ai jamais fait
que j'aurais jamais dit directement
j'aimerais les remercier pour
l'éducation que m'en donner la vie qui
me donnait étant jeune c'est
probablement grâce à vue aujourd'hui que
je suis l'homme que je suis devenu
aujourd'hui et peut-être aussi grâce à
eux de façon pleinement indirects
fortuite qui sont responsables de l'
aventure que je vous racontais
aujourd'hui quand vous les voyez comme
ça un verre à la main plutôt détendu
plutôt sympathique mais détrompez vous
beaucoup de gens sont fait avoir en vous
j'ai eu une éducation extrêmement
stricte
j'étais bien sûr interdit de télé mais
quand j'étais petit j'étais fan de jeux
vidéo et mes parents avaient pris la
mauvaise habitude chaque début de
semaine de cacher les manettes de ma
console quelque part dans l'appartement
et entend comment tout enfant qui se
respecte je passais des heures et des
heures à retourner tous que la maison
pour les retrouver et j'étais pas si
mauvais à ce jeu là jusqu'au jour où ils
ont été plus forts que moi
ils ont tellement bien caché qu'on ne
l'a jamais retrouvée on a passé des
semaines et des semaines aller chercher
on a déménagé trois fois impossible de
remettre la main dessus
cet événement est comme conséquence de
me plonger dans une profonde dépression
j'ai essayé de noyer son chagrin dans
les études il a extrait des études bien
longue bien difficile et dont il choisi
médecine
je suis devenu chirurgien plasticien
inchangé un tacticien petit peu
particulier parce que effectivement la
moitié de mon temps j'ai mes patients à
surmonter leurs complexes je fais la
chirurgie esthétique et l'autre moitié
de mon temps je travaille à gustave
roussy
je serais si vous connaissez gustave
roussy gustave roussy c'est un centre de
lutte contre le cancer
c'est un hôpital un des plus grands
d'europe uniquement dédié au traitement
des patients qui ont un cancer et moi en
tant que chirurgien plasticien je
m'occupe de tout la reconstruction du
sein après les cancers du sein c'est une
pratique que j'affectionne
particulièrement qu'elle permet aux
patientes qui ont le corps qui ont été
abîmés parfois mutilés par la maladie te
retrouver confiance en elle de retrouver
une féminité et de d'espérer garder une
qualité de vie et donc j'avais une
activité plutôt traditionnelle jusqu'au
jour où en novembre 2014 une banque
suisse a eu l'idée géniale qui va
complètement transformer ma pratique
elle a offert à gustave roussy
le robot davinci le robot chirurgical le
plus perfectionné en ce jeu à ce jour
vous pouvez bien imaginer un monstre de
technologie quatre bras articulé piloté
par un chirurgien à une console wii on
va pas aujourd'hui deux manettes
la console a est en haute définition
trois dimensions le robot reproduit
exactement les gestes des chirurgiens et
ça permet donc de faire des
interventions qui était encore alors
impossible à mains nues d'une précision
inégalée
elle permet aussi de supprimer parfois
le tremblement des chirurgiens et on
fait des choses aujourd'hui complètement
incroyable cette machine cette machine
utilisée de façon commune en chirurgie
urologique pour la prod chirurgie la
prostate en chirurgie abdominale et
comme le directeur de l'hôpital nous
aiment bien nous les plasticiens nous
dit voilà vous avez droit d'utiliser le
robot une fois par semaine
alors on était très contents hyper
excité merci beaucoup patron mais qu'est
ce qu'on avait bien pouvoir en faire
parce qu'il faut savoir qu'à ce moment
là personne dans le monde n'avait eu
l'idée d'utiliser cette machine dans le
sang était pas question de passer à côté
de ce petit bijou et donc on a pensé à
la chirurgie d'ablation du sein quand on
retire un saint quelle que soit la
technique on laisse une cicatrice
indélébile qui mesure entre 10 et 20
centimètres au milieu sous seing et
cette cicatrice même après la plus belle
reconstruction du monde quand la
patiente se regarder dans la glace
c'est ce qu'a triste lui rappelle
qu'elle est un cancer et on s'est dit
peut-être qu'avec ce robot on va pouvoir
diminuer les techniques de cette
cicatrice de 3 à 4 cm et non pas la
mettre sur le sein mais en dehors du
sein sous le bras comme ça quand la
patiente a les bras le long du corps
devant la glace
le saint est vierge de tout cicatrices
pendant l'intervention
on s'est dit qu'il fallait absolument
l'associer à une reconstruction
immédiate c'est-à-dire que l'on même
moment de l'ablation du sein
on allait effectuer la reconstruction
dans le a dans la même chirurgie alors
quand on a une nouvelle idée en
chirurgie avant de cesser soit première
patiente il bon ton d'aller au laborde
anatomy c'est un conseil qui vous qui
vaut mieux suivre et donc on a commencé
à essayer de réfléchir un peu comment on
allait effectuer cette intervention puis
la personne que vous voyez en haut à
gauche c'est moi à la console est ce que
vous voyez pas c'est que j'ai un sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles
pourquoi parce que très très vite cette
technique a été possible réalisable
c'est pareil après la bretagne atomique
en fils nouvelles chaînes apparition sur
jcat qui n'a jamais encore été réalisée
c'est un travail d'équipé on n'est
jamais seul dans son camp il faut
travailler qualité il faut travailler
que les affaires mises à jour où est ce
qu'on met le robot est ce qu'on met la
patiente
on a même sacrifié un aux internes pour
le pour l'expérience et on le remercie
encore et donc il a fallu répéter et
répéter cette intervention pour être
prêt le jour j
ça y est on est enfin prêt je remontais
par le directeur on les enseignes et on
a enfin trouvé le moyen d'utiliser on
est prêt pour la première patiente et là
il me dit qu'il a oublié de nous dire un
tout petit détail très bien qu'est-ce
que ça peut bien être et bat aujourd'hui
le robot n'a pas d'autorisation dans le
sein il est interdit d'utiliser le
rebond en chirurgie du sein c'était la
deuxième fois dans ma vie qu'on me
retire les manettes
sauf que cette fois je vais pas me
laisser faire d'abord parce que j'avais
beaucoup ont peur du directoire comme
des parents et deuxièmement parce que
j'étais persuadé de l'intérêt des
technologies pour mes patientes est donc
aujourd'hui en france quand on veut
utiliser une nouvelle technologie qui
n'est pas autorisé dans pour une
intervention
il faut monter une étude de recherche
clinique et si finalement andy
indispensable ça permet d'apporter tout
le cadre sécuritaire pour les patients
il a fallu remplir des centaines et
centaines de papiers et vous connaissez
ni station française a appris des mois
et des mois pour votre réponse
en novembre 2015 on obtient
l'autorisation pour 80 patiente
il ne manquait juste un petit détail
trouver la première patiente qui
accepteraient de bénéficier de cette
chirurgie est donc je vais raconter la
consultation qui je pense ne resteras
gravé toute ma vie en mémoire de cette
patiente qui entre dans mon bureau
s'installe face à moi c'est une patiente
qui avait une mutation génétique qui
prédisposent au cancer du sein est donc
été prévu de réaliser une ablation
préventive de sa poitrine pour limiter
le risque de cancer du sein c'est
exactement une intervention café un
génial jolie et qui était très médiatisé
donc je commençais à l'expliquer
l'intervention classique et les
cicatrices au milieu ou sous le sens et
à la fin de consultation je lui ai dit
que j'avais une idée d'une intervention
de chirurgie robotique qui je pense
pourrait être bénéfique pour elle et
l'avait dit très bien docteur mais
j'imagine ça vous l'avez déjà réalisés
bah non pas du tout si je réussis en
fait vous vous serez ma première
patiente hockey est très bien vous êtes
allez vous former ailleurs vers l'est
sur gens qui savent le faire c'est bien
le problème c'est qu'à ce jour personne
n'a encore utiliser le robot dans le
sein et je le fait d'avoir 100 kg sur le
sein c'est que quelque chose qui est
qu'il a travaillé beaucoup et qui on
sentait que c'était vraiment quelque
chose qui était important pour elle elle
m'a fait une réponse très simple
elle me regarde dans les yeux et m'a dit
simplement docteur vous avez toute ma
confiance
alors ok on y va
s élever à quitter mon box de
consultation et là il faut bien imaginer
un peu ce qui se passe dans ma tête je
viens devant une patiente qui était
prête à faire une intervention que je
n'avais jamais réalisé
donc je n'étais même pas sûr à 100%
qu'elles étaient réalisables et j'ai
fait travailler des équipes pendant des
semaines et des semaines pour 7 pour
cette chirurgie donc à ce moment là
l'échec était inenvisageable la première
intervention a duré plus de sept heures
aujourd'hui j'ai réalisé cette attention
plus de 140 fois on met moins d'une
heure et demie des patients viennent du
monde entier pour bonifier cette
technique parce que ne pas avoir des
cicatrices sur le sein c'est quelque
chose qui est très important pour elle
on a des chirurgiens qui vient de se
former de partout dans le monde
la première était fait il n'ya pas
longtemps aux états unis une autre
brésil et la bonne nouvelle c'est que
suite aux bons résultats d'étude
la société qui a construit le robot a
déposé une demande d'autorisation pour
que cette technique soit dispensé
partout dans le monde vous montrer un
exemple de résultats donc cette patiente
essais avant l'intervention
semeta cette patiente à une mutation
génétique prédisposant au cancer et donc
il est nécessaire de réaliser une
ablation complète de la poitrine et une
reconstruction
voici le résultat après c'est vers ce
type de résultat qu'il faut se battre
aujourd'hui en reconstruction humeur une
géorgie de plus en plus discrète
le moins invasive le moins mutilante qui
permet à la passion de reprendre une
activité normale le plus vite possible
et laisser la maladie derrière elle la
cicatrice elle est loin du sein sous le
bras et elles mesurent entre 3 et 4 cm
donc pour conclure j'ai pas vous parler
de l'intérêt de penser hors du cadre ou
que peut-être certaines frustrations
d'enfance amène de grands projets
je vais vous parler de super pouvoirs
d'un super pouvoir qui est en chacun
d'entre nous et qui est essentiel pour
faire pour faire avancer le monde
aujourd'hui
ce super pouvoirs c'est la capacité que
l'on a a donné sa confiance à quelqu'un
j'ai eu la chance dans ma vie de
rencontrer des super héroïne c'est super
héroïne ce sont tous des patientes qui
ont accepté de se faire opérer en
chirurgie robotique et fait renaître ce
projet est d'ailleurs je les remercie et
j'aimerais leur dédier cette
présentation
parce qu'il faut savoir que dans tout
projet
quelle que soit la discipline on a juste
besoin parfois d'une seule personne et
cette personne peut être chacun d'entre
vous qui s'assoient en face de vous qui
vous regarde dans les yeux et qui vous
dit alors ok on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]